having I think that the courage to stand
on something that doesn't feel
establishment popular or mainstream
media popular but that you understand is
what people are actually feeling and you
know I'm very much a person that from
the very beginning has said f Ukraine
you know I stand on that and I I would
have said it if I was in the debate
stage like I would have let them all do
their little pitch in the cries tears
because how this gets into the YF
Ukraine is what I yeah because Rich
because Richmond north of Richmond you
know what I mean that because Richard
muffin motion because people literally
can't put food on the table you've
stopped people from working in America
uh the average person is struggling to
even be able to afford gas groceries uh
you have people that are dealing with an
influx of crime and illegal immigration
in their cities peoples whose daughters
and kids are being raped and killed that
woman that was horrifically killed in
Arizona going on a run by an illegal
immigrant all this is happening in our
country right here